so i know all of you guys have so many
questions on your mind that's why i'm
here to help you everybody
hi i'm ij hey
you're not ij
guys i just got finished editing a video
so i'm super tired so today is going to
be hot mess edition of ask ij
i
did actually just get done editing a
video and
i am feeling a little tired my hair is
in my face it's what happens when you
have long lubricants
it is time for a twitter question
i mean
twitter question did i know that ketchup
was discovered in the 30s as cough syrup
syrup syrup
why am i shedding
who who made my hair no actually i
didn't but now i do so me and brian are
going to my favorite burger place it's
called father's office but they they
don't give you ketchup so when you go
there you have to bring your own
i'm going to zip
my favorite superhero is by far the
power rangers miss julie wants to know
what genre of movie i would like to
appear in probably like a drama maybe or
a comedy these are two very opposite
things thomas wants to know why it takes
me so long between ask ij episodes you
know i
just don't know
sometimes i like to stare at the tv and
look at my pretty long hair
because it reminds me of goldilocks
sarah wants to know how i set up my
lighting it's pretty simple actually i
have a lamp behind me
and in front of me i have a bright
studio light that kind of just bounces
off the white walls and illuminates
everything
xca7
asks
what is your favorite show obviously ask
ij mia wants to know where you can find
the yerba that i'm always drinking and
all my daily booth photos you can check
out their website gayaki.com and there's
a little locator and you can also find
it almost like whole foods and trader
joe's i think might have it
trick-or-treating is steve jobs house
you know that would be amazing except uh
he kind of has a restraining order
against me
i don't know why
daily booth question ballin wants to
know where he got my power balance
bracelet at um i bought it off their
online store supposedly it's supposed to
keep you balanced i feel like it's all
kind of a mental thing but it still
looks cool makes me feel really cool i
don't know if it makes me feel balanced
or not but
i got one can i backflip it no i i can't
i'm not even going to try it unless you
want to see a dead ij and you guys have
seen enough dead ijs mikey lucas
wants to know if i'm coming to england
anytime soon i'm i really don't have any
plans to come there anytime too soon but
i mean i would like to one day what's
the worst thing that made my parents
really upset i used to slam the door
that used to make them
very angry i also once climbed out on my
roof because i thought it would be a
good idea yeah they didn't really like
that so much either how tall am i i am
five three
and a half i know pretty tall huh
facebook question roxanne no i didn't
dress up for halloween but i did go to
radio shack wearing some vampire fangs
i love how i'm just following you around
what are you doing now what are you
doing now it's cool
my favorite vampire diaries character is
by far damon
i love him judy wants to know how many
concerts i've been to in my life
honestly i've lost track when i was in
college i would go to four or five a
week that's a lot could be why i'm
partially deaf taylor wants to know
monster or red bull yeah neither
this is the stuff alicia wants me to
meowl and dedicate the meowth to her so
alicia this meow is for you
justin bieber for president yes no yes
would i rather be stuck in a room with
the jersey shore cast or the cast of
lost are you kidding me obviously the
cast of lost oh tom wants to know what
my first name is
youtube question what am i going to do
for my 40th episode of ask ij you know
what i don't even know is this the 40th
episode i don't think so in the last
episode i was looking for a reason to go
to canada and it looks like abby x2511
gave me a good enough reason to go
justin bieber's from canada
barbie orchid wants to know if i'd
rather be snookie or jaywile from the
jersey shore not gonna lie i don't
really want to be either one of them
zinni wants to know what i'd look like
with pigtails
yeah we're gonna put that back down
would i come to australia
yes
gonna have to say my favorite animal is
a dog specifically puppies even more
specifically cute puppies my inspiration
to start vlogging was mostly out of
boredom and also i really like to be
creative so i feel like this is sort of
my little creative outlet
here on the internet now i can't say
that i actually go back and watch some
of my old youtube videos but a lot of
times you guys will ask me questions
that sometimes reference things that
happened a long time ago so i can pull
some of those video clips and show them
here would i ever do a bungee jump
honestly i probably wouldn't because i'm
kind of afraid of heights so that's kind
of like jumping off something really
high and
only having a cord to save your life no
not gonna do that
stop making sounds up there i'm
recording video video response hey
that's awesome that i justine got a
playstation three i wonder what games
she plays three i've got to start the
party for we move the kung fu rider ipad
uh sports champions
battlefield which i actually haven't
started playing yet because i've been
playing modern warfare 2 call of duty
hello and a little big
these are my games thank you guys so
much for watching this episode of ask ij
i love reading all of your questions and
your comments and watching all of your
video responses because you guys are
pretty pretty pretty funny now my
question for you guys for the next
episode is what were you for halloween
it was a few things i was a large ipod
shuffle for shane dawson's video
and i the second thing is i randomly
just wore some things around
the night before or halloween we're
gonna go into radio shack i gotta buy uh
i gotta buy a cord so uh yeah i'm going
into the vampire
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of ask ij if you wanna ask me
questions you can ask me questions on
twitter on facebook on youtube and even
on dailybooth don't forget to click
subscribe so you'll know when i launch
another fun video and check out my other
ijustine youtube channel where i post
fun vlogs from
fun things yeah that's it see you guys
in the next video that i post and um
love you bye